grow
side
directly
falling through the bridge and here we and the
blows at about ten in the evening was at 10 11
between this I don’t remember exactly this I hear
barbar broads came out to look from
that anton narrow remnants of the glow of the day
is heard and but I realized that something is
not there but  because the Ukrainians will not calm down
until the place is finished off, it seems to have finished off
thank God that I understand that it needs
to be repaired that they
still did it there in the Soviet Union they did it
well because how much I drove
before that the upper layer was destroyed
and the lower one was mostly
strong again  the grains are good for me too, now they are
doing it in the morning today I see a number of shamasses
are closed I came to see and strongly do not
let it in, but before that they also hit in a heap
almost the same place they
hit, that is, for several days they shot
it on the 19th they shot 20 they shot
and
sit on nan